The Joe Rogan experience in a way.
I think that one of the cultural
jobs this podcast has performed,
and this is like whether
deliberately or not,
is it demonstrates that the old political
lines that we used to comfortably
abide within a starting
to sort of break down,
cause you know like something like an
obvious signifier of a particular type of
person IEI go hunting now we have to
accept is coupled with your view that the
agricultural industry needs
to be regulated and it's
disgusting. Now they're,
you know,
they're,
we have complete and total agreement
and we both can see that the way that
legislation is set up is biased
towards corporate interests,
commercial interests and profit. Yeah.
And so for me, bloody whether or not,
you know, Chris Pat Prime in the name of
sheep, I think he had no problem, man.
Whoa, whoa. That's not, I don't need
to spend my time worrying about that.
I'm a little bit like Alex Jones,
like with the,
why are we worrying about flat earth if
they've got them babies and all of that
stuff is, I feel like why don't we focus
on the things that are making a genuine
difference to the uh, the way
people are living lives. Yeah.
And it seems to me that the one of the
priorities is in a new global landscape
that we're living with.
What are the dominant forces and what
are the goals of the dominant forces and
how detached or those goals from the
lives of what you might say are ordinary
people or the majority of people
to use it less complex term.
And what's probably most terrific about
reforming the system is that the people
that are going to suffer the most
are the people that are the poorest.
So if you think of like a fast
food in particular, right?
There's a lot of like really poor people
that re rely on fast food because it's
very inexpensive.
If you go and you can get a
lot of calories for a small
amount of money, right?
But if you go from the fast
food restaurant and then
you'd go down the line to
factory farming and then somehow know
that they eliminate factory farming and
they say, no, no, if you're
going to raise animals,
you have to have the same
sort of standards that we
would expect if we knew you.
If we were there, we want pastures, we
went animals living in the wild. We want,
I mean, you know, fenced in, but
like living like an actual animal,
not this crazy warehouse bullshit.
You guys are running well,
that's going to up our operation costs.
Well then that's how it's going to be.
So then the beef becomes
far more expensive.
Now the beef becomes far more
expensive than what a fast food.
What are the restaurants do?
Well,
they're going to have to make
things more expensive too.
So who's going to suffer the poor people
who's going to suffer with cheap meat
and supermarkets,
poor people that can't afford it now.
But I think that what happens
though is you start to put,
you have started to pull a Fred
that reveals how the, the fabric
of our culture is corrupted because it
shouldn't be more expensive than the
reason it's more expensive is because
everything is put into a capital based
ideology.
We're already,
I've heard many times on this show
you discussing universal basic income.
This is that the beginning of looking at
alternative economic models and there's
an argument for saying everyone
has the right to nutritious diet.
Everyone has the right to a safe home.
You know,
so like if we start prioritizing those
ideas above these organizations have the
right to maximize profit,
we were holding a snake,
then maximizing profit that's
getting taken off the table.
And then there comes your
counterargument about innovation. Well,
I would say if innovation slows
no problem because we've all,
we've decided as a culture to prioritize
housing and nutrition for the majority
of people. Now you can still say
that starts to, you know, that's,
that's kind of socialism but,
and I don't think that that can work on a,
on a continental scale.
I think you have to,
we have to break down centralized systems,
whether those are corporate,
centralized systems or national,
I feel that we, these two,
the time has gone where there's too
much diversity. Like they're not too,
they're probably always was diversity.
People are different.
We are influenced by our culture is
our schools, our education, our class,
our race is all of these factors.
And then to expect us all to live in
this sort of single bandwidth of this is
what America is all, this is what
France is or this is what England is.
People at these two different now.
But what it does,
it seems like the standards we
were adhering to unconsciously
or otherwise, he's,
these groups have the right to make as
much money as they can and to interfere
with that is an American or British
or wherever it was. Cause you know,
beyond the national ideas, I'm
sure. So you know for me that's the,
you pull that thread out. It's the
poor that will suffer within, no,
we have to rule out the poor suffer.
So we had, so what happens in the end,
you start to get into
redistribution of resources,
managing and regulate in the
power of the most powerful people.
And whenever that conversation starts,
it gets shut down because
we want to conserve,
even in a capitalist system.
Wouldn't it be more ethical if everybody
started from the same starting block?
Well, that's what's wrong
with the world, right?
What's wrong with the world
that some people are in a,
they have a terrible hand of
cards you've been dealt. You know,
and my point about food is that the
people that are going to see they're going
to suffer the most are the people
that rely on the cheap food. Yes,
you'll play as that cheat
food gets pulled away,
then a lot of those
supermarkets in a lot of those,
um, fast food stores that rely on
that factory farm food, you know,
they're going to be in a bad situation.
Things are gonna be much more expensive.
And if things are much more, if it, and
if they make animals live, like, um,
what is that guy's name?
Uh, Polyface farms.
Joel's Salitan. Yeah,
he's a fascinating cat.
I had him on my podcast before
he sort of a farm reformist.
And what he believes is that these
animals should live just like animals.
When he has pigs, he puts
them in a, a fenced area,
but he moves the fence Darya every day.
So like the pigs move to a different spot
and so they're just constantly forging
and eating acorns and uh,
but they're, you know,
they're living like a pig.
They're living in a natural,
they're not living in some
crazy warehouse. Yes it
does. Same with his chickens.
He has this mobile chicken coop and
he moves it from pasture to pasture.
And this is how
he operates his entire farm.
Yes.
It seems again the appointment it's been,
we've talked about earlier that
we ought to like if we look at,
no one knows what's right.
So perhaps what we could try and do
is replicate what we do naturally.
And so there is an argument that
naturally we do hunt. There is a,
an argument that naturally we do eat meat.
There isn't actually grow food too though.
Right.
Is an argument that like total saying,
like getting into organic gardening,
if you have your own garden man mean
that is like one of the most Karma free
things ever. If you can figure out
a way to have your own compost,
your own garden, and you don't ever have
to rely on anybody else for your food,
well then you're not
participating in that shit at all.
Do you think that the spirit
of entrepreneurship could
be turned to designing
these systems?
Do you think the only thing
that incentivizes people is
maximum profit? I do too.
I think that it is possible that
people would sit around and go,
how do we organize a society that is
fair and just that doesn't kill people's
individualism or creativity or right
to pursue different goals are to be who
they are and belief who you know.
But like I feel like there's
so much fog in the air.
People don't know what they
actually believe in because
there's so much powerful
cultural influence, so
much toxin, physical toxin,
literal toxins and toxicity,
cultural toxicity. You know, how are,
how am I to,
Eh protect my children from
cultural influences that tell them,
do you have to look this way,
be this way, behave that way.
These are the things that call, if
you're not this, you're not a man.
If you're not this, you're
not a woman. You know, like w
like, you know, as a parent,
I feel the obligation to
create an environment where
they can grow up to be who
they are. I mean, in fact it me,
and then when you've sort of scaled
it up to a society, you know,
how can we start to recognize,
look is this time to look at
different systems for living. And I,
what I feel is people want
to be involved in that,
in the power systems that affect them.
Like if you have a group
of a hundred people,
they want a bit bow to run their own
schools, run their own care systems, run,
it'd be in charge of them.
And I've not just be some little beam of
energy flicked about by cultural forces
that they can't reach or touch.
It's alien a in and like one of the
things in Marxism and that you know,
and I know very little about this subject,
did he say that when capitalism
reaches a certain point,
people will be glossed,
alienated.
They feel like a cog in a machine.
No one will have no pride in their work.
No one will know what it's like to
make a whole bicycle and finger look,
I made that.
You'll just,
you're the guide that makes the pedals
now fuck off home. You know, now like,
you know,
like I've listened to enough Jordan
Peterson to understand that there are
limitations to what socialism
and Marxism can achieve.
But just because you know,
capitalism is better than feudalism,
that doesn't mean that's the end of
the conversation that we shouldn't be
looking for. Fair about. I'm
more just ways of living. Well.